so i have two guests here with me that
uh their videos have been going viral
the last week both of them are
restaurant owners one of them is based
out of sherman oaks california angela
marston the other one is david morris
based out of uh michigan and
they both made a video very different
type of a messaging what's funny is
neither one of them have met each other
till today's video they were talking
offline
before us going live and i wanted to
bring this to your attention because
a lot of business owners in america are
doing their part to create jobs and
help others who are not wanting to rely
on the economy to go to work to do their
part to pay their bills to
do what they need to do and they're
trying to do their best to follow the
guidelines
but unfortunately politics gets in the
way
of these two entrepreneurs that we have
here with us david and angela thank you
so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
thank you you're very welcome so neither
one of you have seen each other's video
right you you haven't fully seen each
other's video on what happened there
right is that a fair
assessment there that's correct yeah
okay and and if you don't mind angela
maybe
maybe take a moment and tell us what's
been happening with you in your
restaurant in the last week or two
um well in the last week here in
california um
they've just been doing more and more
lockdowns so
two days before thanksgiving we got
noticed that all outdoor dining
which we worked very hard to do
and put up spend about 60 to 80 000
doing all the changes over the last year
that they wanted
um was going to be shut down the night
before thanksgiving
um and you know
basically i had to let my staff know
that they didn't have a job for the
holidays because we can't sustain with
to go
to go is about 10 we make gross about 10
we lose about 90 profit and anybody
knows anything about a brick and mortar
business
and a restaurant the margins are very
thin and the costs are very high
i tried to stay open uh the first time
around for to go
for my customers and also for the
community because the community
really missed you and in la we have a
lot of people that are older and alone
or they're living alone because they've
moved here and all their families out of
state
so connection and community is very very
vital to them
so they did come out for to go and it
broke my heart but
i didn't have enough money to sustain
this time
so i had to shut down completely now
when for for people to understand
running a business
how many employees do you have your
employees one day when that when you
shut down
are they getting any kind of a comp
money from the state is this
oh my god what is us the details behind
it well i wish this
restaurant was in indiana or michigan
because in la you know we
are at a gradual climb up to 15 an hour
the expenses are very high here the
rents are very high we were already
losing businesses to the minimum wage
hike
many of my other competitors and friends
were closing because of the minimum wage
hike so when this went down
um no uh unemployment's all they had
you know they could rely on and then i
was lucky enough to get the ppp
loan but the ppp loan only lasts for two
and a half months
mind you i got a hundred thousand
dollars i have 15
employees um pre pandemic
and um basically that's roughly you know
my payroll is roughly 25 to 30
000 a month and and so between rent and
that
it lasted two and a half months and we
weren't
actually allowed to be fully open either
so i kind of did
stretch that you know because i i once
we went to to go i basically went down
to four
four employees from 15.
from 15 to four employees and these are
in a small business everybody works like
a family and when you're 15 employees
everybody knows each other especially
restaurant you're talking to each other
you don't call a boss it's just
friendship relationship that there's
there
what did these 11 employees of yours
slash
friends of yours are you working with
what did they how how would they paying
a price for you having to let them go
oh i have a cat just just a little
history of my
my pub it's been here since 1978 it's
one of the few
um holdovers of the cheers bars
on the third owner the kitchen staff
has been there since 1978.
wow and they are a brother george um who
works the day shift
miguel works at night and runs the
kitchen does the grocery shopping and
the cleaning
his wife does dishes and buses and now
his son has come in
um so my entire kitchen
their household their entire household
depends on
me solely they've never had another job
since 1978. now my front house
i had yeah at my front house i had staff
that had been with me since day one i've
had it 10 years so
i had a bartender that had been with me
10 years that i lost through this
you know because he had to go and try to
find other means of work and
you know i had some that i was able to
keep um
but yeah i mean they have to find other
work and if they can't find other work
they got to rely on unemployment
i can't afford to pay them to stay at
home i don't have that kind of extra
funds
so here's a question for you did it
create any kind of friction between you
and them because a lot of times
situations like this
what they do is they're they could say
well angela you don't understand the
situation i'm going through it's my wife
i've been there since 78 and i have a
son and my
you know we're running this thing
together you know you got to can you
help us out and then you want to help
them out you can't help them out
did it cost any friction between you and
your employees
you know it didn't i will say in the
beginning
um you know miguel who runs my kitchen
the other caveat with with
my with miguel and his wife who run my
kitchen is
is they were here in a work visa for
many years and they had just
applied for their citizenship in
february
and had gotten it and they were waiting
for the paperwork but then the paperwork
got postponed
and he was terrified to apply for
unemployment even though he's been
paying in the system forever
because he's afraid until he got that
actual certificate in his hand
he was afraid to take money from the
government
so um for me his brother
george was able to get unemployment
and i paid him out of what funds i had
to keep him going and then luckily the
ppp what
really i stayed open as an essential
business
and i employed him and um i did to go
and i was bleeding about 30 000 a month
um
loss staying open for to go but
you know i had to keep them employed i
mean what are they going to do that's
right what are they going to do you know
what i mean
oh no question you see sometimes uh when
uh
you look at the media sometimes they
portray business owners as being these
rich greedy people that all they care
about is themselves
but they don't see the story behind
closed doors where
folks have stayed with the same place
since 1978
and a family four people have a job from
the same family
working for you i think what i'd like to
do is i like the audience
to see which video was that was viral
and uh
you know david maybe this will kind of
give you an idea what story she was
selling and then i want to kind of share
with everybody else the audience that
hasn't seen
what mayor garcetti had to say about
your video here's the video
so this is my place the pineapple hill
grill in saloon if you go to my page you
can see all the work i did
for outdoor dining for tables being
seven feet apart
and i come in today because i'm
organizing a protest
and i came in to get stuff for that
and i walk into my parking lot and
obviously mayor garcetti has approved
[Music]
this
has approved
this being set up for this
being set up for for a movie company
i'm losing everything everything i own
is being taken away from me
and they set up a movie company right
next
to my outdoor patio which is right over
here
and people wonder why i'm protesting
and why i have had enough
they have not given us money and they
have shut us down we cannot survive my
staff cannot survive
look at this
tell me that this is dangerous
but right next to me is a slap in my
face
that's safe this is safe
50 feet away
this is dangerous mayor garcetti and
gavin newsom is responsible
for every single person that doesn't
have unemployment
that does not have a job and all the
businesses that are going under
and we need your help we need somebody
to do something about this
david what's your reaction when you see
that video right there with angela
hey that's bringing tears to my eyes
that bothers me tremendously okay
um that is heart-wrenching and i'm sorry
that bothers me
but um you know what you know what's
intense i want to read this to everybody
that's watching this mayor garcetti
responded and he gave a statement
before i read the statement this is
what's going on with california
california has declared
the entertainment industry workers
essential that's what was going on
50 feet away from where you were at and
in la county they must follow strict
guidelines
such as eating and staggered shifts or
in an area large enough to stay
six feet apart restrictions la county is
shutting down all dining at restaurants
breweries wineries and bars
for at least three weeks starting
wednesday november 25th which is which
was two weeks ago amid a surge in
coronavirus
cases health official announced sunday
and mayor garcetti said
my heart goes out to miss marston
and the workers at the pineapple hill
saloon who have to comply with the state
and county public health
restrictions that close outdoor dining
no one likes these restrictions but i do
support them
as our hospital icu bed filled to
capacity and cases have increased by 500
we must stop this virus before it kills
thousands of more
angelinos angela angela what do you have
to say with what mayor garcia had to say
to you
i'm out i'm i'm outraged you know i
since then we've we i've
made some progress and we just run we
just won um with a judge in the la
courts
and the judge ruled in our favor and
said that it was arbitrary
it was it was not backed by science but
you know what i need why
what i like to say to him and what i
have already said is
do not sit and tell me that there are
stay-at-home orders
because that is not real there is 50
percent of us
out here that cannot stay at home and
work off zoom
and work off tech or have rich families
so when you say we're in this together
and you say oh
you know you can stay at home you're
you're lying
that is not an option you know you're
making people choose between
having a place to live and eat
or or not like this is life in death
situation you know this is evictions
this is not no food forget the fact that
i have
children i have employees with children
that have no money now for christmas
they can't
they're wondering what they're going to
get how they're going to get through
even christmas let alone paying the rent
my manager was crying
her unemployment is done it's up and
there's no
we don't know they have come up with
nothing they're on vacation right now
there's no emergency session for us to
get our you know
ppp or unemployment and and it's
ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous it is are you open now are
you open right now or no
no i am i will say that through this
we've been blessed we've had a lot of
donations
and um i have been sticking with what i
said in the beginning which is i will
not stop until they let us open and i'm
speaking on behalf of
all small businesses here now but i'm
hoping
friday that i'll be able to go over some
numbers now and with the help i mean
i've gotten support from all over the
world i had
amaze the most amazing like thing
happened um
uh brooks burgers in florida they own uh
three hamburger uh places there
called me and said i wanna i wanna
support you from over the pond because
we don't need the government to take
care of us
we can take care of each other and he
offered to pay a month worth of rent
and that's another restaurants here in a
state that's open
powerful i mean i i was crying he
i mean just today he called and he said
you know i decided
you know my rent's like ten thousand so
he said i'm going to send you 5000 right
away
and this this really obviously triggered
me and he said
i think we're going to do a take the
rest and have the customers do
like we'll do a celebration and a
fundraiser and have them match it so we
can get you more money
i could not stop crying because when i
had my bar
every christmas i did bad santa
christmas
and it would be a fundraiser and i would
raise funds for
the orphanages and for the other
community and then now
i'm in this situation and the kindness
of this person it was
it was i don't have words to explain the
generosity
the humanity the kindness and outpour
and and i'm just great to see great to
see because
other restaurant owners and business
owners obviously know the challenges you
guys are going through
you know there's a community and and the
benefit the
the restaurant owner in florida has over
you is
the desantis's regulations in florida
are very different than newsom's
regulations in the state of california
has this event at all influenced you to
consider moving to another state
um you know honestly um right before
this happened i'm from indiana
all my family's there and um my mom said
angela
just throw in the towel come back home
live with us
open a place here and
i couldn't i sat and i thought about i
said mom and you know
my mom worked in a bread factory she's a
very determined woman
woman so i i called her i said mom
i've been in la 28 years this is my town
and people are fleeing out of it and
nobody
is doing anything about it and i said i
can't just leave i have to finally
start telling the truth and showing
people what's going on
instead of keeping it in you know it's
it i just can't
i can't i have five bar owner friends
who haven't been able to
open for nine months because they don't
have food they don't have food in their
establishment
they one of them has gone through their
life savings and their unemployment's
almost up
the other one is took out a personal
loan neither of them got ppp's
the other one has two bars she'd just
gotten her second one a year ago
they're done i mean we are losing we
lost 110 000 restaurants
and that was before this closure so i
can't just leave i
can't i got to do something i have to
move the giant
because somebody's got to stand up for
this community
you know well more power to you just so
you know there's a lot of people in the
state of california that would like
more folks like yourself to be vocal
because sometimes people can't speak for
themselves and it's great to see
your video going viral on twitter
getting 9.2 million views
the challenge is i mean on gofundme you
know thank god there's a product like
gofundme
invented by capitalist that allows times
like this for people to take advantage
of it i believe you've been able to
raise
uh 183 thousand dollars we're going to
put the link
below as well which just tells you how
much support you have but i wonder for
the other business owners that have lost
their restaurants
who couldn't get a video to go viral or
somehow somebody
didn't go their way they have to shut
down and those 15 employees are lost so
david
when it comes down to yourself how
similar is your story you're not in
california you're michigan
how similar or different is your story
from angela's
well we've got some we've got some
differences and at the heart we've got
some very uh
good similarities the difference is uh
you know she's got a liquor license
and in michigan those who would like to
open back up and do some things as soon
as they do try to do that they get their
liquor license
i'm not experiencing that i don't have
that threat hanging over me
uh she employs more people than i do i
bought this later in life when my kids
were raised and me and my wife
just paid it off and trying to do a
little pension pad here for ourselves
and it's her and i and and my son helps
out and then i got two cooks and a
waitress
we laid off two of them right away back
in march
back then you know they had the stimulus
package and they were getting the
uh extended benefits with the
unemployment amounts
and uh it that seemed to sustain
everybody probably more than it should
have i gotta say that
um but people come out and they
supported us we're more of a
small tight knit you know hey we only
see 40 people so we're on different
spectrums here a little bit
um but with the traffic flow we have in
the in the neighborhood we have
uh it's worked for us for 12 years and
to watch it slowly erode
over the course of the summer and you
know even at half capacity the customers
were supporting us with takeouts well
you know when the unemployment rate out
uh the stimulus monies ran out we get
into fall time
and we were doing okay and then we got
into the return of the school
students uh maybe halloween a lot of
contacts surface contact things there
that i seen kind of would would
start exploding these numbers and they
come right back in the same small
segment of the economy
and said hey you're you know basically
you're to blame we got to shut you down
again
and you know out here we're different
because we don't have the sunlight and
the heat and the warmth
she's got perfect scenario out there
design outside with the sanitization
measures
uh i we don't even have that opportunity
to have them shut her down i don't
understand
um but um i want to show you
i want i want to show your video for the
audience to see and as well as angela
she hasn't seen it yet
because your videos is
you know it was prom impromptu you
weren't even ready for it it just kind
of happened i want to share this with
the audience because it's a
very interesting setting on what
happened with yours
uh uh somebody's telling the news and
then all of a sudden you walk up on them
and then this is what takes place
newschannel 3's tavarius haywood joins
us live in portage
with the details on why the judge
said no javarius is everything okay
okay my government leaders have
abandoned me are you
are you the owner of four trillion
dollars of
stimulus money i gave it to who special
interest groups and campaign donors i'm
dave morris i own the place
so what's going on what's going on you
know what's going on tell me you tell me
hey we got a government that has taken
the stimulus money
they gave it to special campaign donors
they gave it to special interest
they abandoned me and they put me in a
position where
i have to fight back you could have
given me money i'd gladly walk away for
60 days and let this virus settle down
i'm not going to do it alone okay are
you going to continue to violate the
state's orders and stay open
state order this isn't an order this is
a conspiracy this is a tyranny
what do you want to tell other
restaurant owners who wake up stand up
this is america be free
it's time to rise up gotcha that rides
up shut it all down
or don't shut any of us down that's the
only way to get control of a virus
angela what do you think when you see
his reaction here in the interview i say
amen
amen that was a little different style
of passions we had there but uh
amen i mean here people were afraid were
afraid you know that we're going to get
boycotted we're afraid that people are
going to think we want to kill them
because you know
you know we don't believe in covet or we
don't you know
i i it's i
commend you and i wish and i hope that
whatever we're doing
creates a revolt with the businesses
because
this is outrageous i mean
the courts the judge and the court get
this
found that not only were they in
violation
right and they they were overstepping
their power by shutting us down
but that 3.1 of
all cases of going out were
from outdoor dining and the majority of
those
were coming from fast food chain
restaurants i've got an in-n-out burger
that has 50 people in line every day as
i sit here shuttered
and that's what they were shutting us
down on you know that's what a judge
ruled was you know overstepping their
power
you know they've destroyed half the city
based on nothing it's i i
i love i love what you did
i love it i wish it would be more
contagious over here
we hope to get there okay that it was
very uh
it was fortunate for me but i didn't i
didn't plan on knowing that because i
asked them not to come around that day
they weren't relaying my messages here
in michigan
uh i'm i'm just you know 25 30 minutes
from the
invisible border i call it where they
can go down to indiana and they can eat
and dine
and i've had too many customers telling
me the weather's getting cold they're
going down to the christmas shop they're
stopping for breakfast
and then they're coming back into
michigan after they have dinner and
doing the christmas shopping see
and that started to irritate me my local
media wouldn't say that
and i started talking what you just said
there about i seen a bus at my local
drive-thru national chain
and there were several people on it and
they were walking them down in the
aisles and no mask on them and they just
went through the drive through and i'm
saying
hey come on man who's that guy in front
of me that gave him 75 cents and
quarters
nice guy behind me gets them they're
trying to convince us that there is no
surface contact
this is a virus and i refuse to accept
the fact that if there's
they're trying to tell me a little
microorganism's going to float around
the sky for 10 minutes
and it's you know wait for the nice guy
to come sucking in
well hey hey they're trying to tell me
that if you have a special permit
the virus won't get you because the
virus recognizes you have a permit
see what this is what they're doing i
mean do they'd like to think people
believe that this
this air's stagnant you know i got a
small cafe there okay and i've got an
overly large hood system it's kind of a
a hindrance on me because i get utility
bills and when somebody opens my front
door
my swing door into my kitchen goes open
by four inches and it all goes up the
hood system
and to tell me i've got a stagnant
airflow where it's just sitting in there
mingling
no way and if so i brought it to their
attention earlier in the week about the
uh cdc uh then i went on the newest
update since october and september and
they talk about surface contact
how long does the covet 19 stay on
surface two hours up to a couple days
so i still say we got a lot of people
that are cross contaminating in the
grocery stores in the department stores
and
um they're not washing their hands
before they put down you know what right
now as we speak
they put stricter rules in they've shut
down
playgrounds hair salons nail salons
listen parks zoos listen
tj maxx is packed with christmas
shoppers and so is the indoor mall
the indoor mall that doesn't take a
temperature
doesn't wear a glove doesn't have a mask
it's packed with people trying on
different clothes
and they're open right now as we speak
that's right i made a banner
a big red banner and it said if divided
we fall
closed them all now yeah it was t-h-e-m
but when you read it fast it's closed
them all
so i put that in my on the front
on the fence and some people get it some
don't but my
you know my exactly what you're saying
is what i'm complaining about the
inconsistencies policy
and um uh i don't know let me kind of
share with the audience what the
restrictions they said in your state in
michigan
uh governor uh whitmer your governor
administration on sunday ordered high
schools and colleges
uh to stop in person classes close
restaurants to indoor dining and stop
organized sports in a bid to
curb michigan's uh spiking coronavirus
cases right
started november 18th wednesday in the
last three weeks dan continues for
restaurants and bars dining
service likely will not be allowed to
resume with the current set of
restrictions
expires on december 20th michigan
department of health and human services
director robert gordon says
on the bottom a justin winslow who's the
president and ceo of the restaurant
association
he said the following says we firmly
believe there's a better approach
one followed by 45 other states that
doesn't use
blunt force closure of a single industry
to resolve a shared crisis
he pointed out that michigan restaurant
dining rooms will be closed for 118 days
in 2020 that's nearly four months by
december 20 the restaurant industry lost
eight billion dollars in sales
and laid off 75 of its workforce
for that time what has changed since
that day
when your video went viral on twitter
what's changed david what's happened to
you
all they did was extend it now if
there's things changed for me personally
believe me
i didn't expect that go viral that was a
big surprise uh him being there and me
surprising him and it kind of spread to
me when i pulled in to drop
off goods there's a lot of things that's
changed in my personal life where all of
a sudden i'm able to kind of
uh encourage people to stand up in the
cafe
it's been tremendous change we've had so
much support so many people coming
um and you know i i like to say we've
had on first part was kind of negative
for me because on a personal basis
people like to attack you they think
that you're the only one yeah but you're
out to kill society yeah
and um i've had death threats you know
it's when my when my grandchildren have
to read that it bothered me it hurt my
heart a little bit
and i asked my dog just don't let him
read it because anytime you're going to
stand up to something that you then you
know
that you've just been pushed to the
point and you're true in
in in what you're doing not everybody's
going to like that okay
you can't ever be 100 popular but you
got to do it and we got to teach our
kids
we're doing this for our grandkids by
the way i don't want people to forget
this
i'm after my liberty i want it back i
want my freedoms back in this country
i want us to have the right to choose
and the people that abused me
uh verbally on the social sites uh it
was pretty easy just to say i don't pull
you into my cafe i don't go out and
twist the army naked in here okay
and we have continued to defy they took
my license a couple of days ago wow
uh they i know where i was gonna go next
that was my next
question for you so here's a question
for both of you how concerned are you
knowing both of you are in an industry
where you
angel on this side you have a liquor
license and you
you need licenses you need permits you
need certain
you need certain things to happen and
that's led by the local
politicians local whoever government
employees that may be
how concerned are you that if they
really wanted to push you around they
could
you know what well i'm sorry but my
response to that is i'm 59 years old
okay
i've struck i won't say i've struggled
but i've i've pulled myself up by the
bootstraps many times and i've worked
too hard for somebody to push me into
that corner
with no say so and drive me into
bankruptcy and then think i'm gonna go
away quietly and forget about me
i would do my best to raise the troops
in this country
we are duel for this and i'm not going
to fear this i keep thinking back to
when my father grandfathers and
forefathers fought for my freedoms
and the older i get the more important
that he comes to me for my grandchildren
my great-grandchildren
and i we can't fear this and i that's
what i'm telling you
you can't fear the concept if we all
come up together
and i know the problem we i know your
problem and i know our problem here i
got friends that own these
uh like i say restaurants with liquor
license it's a little more difficult
uh they'll be the next step but somehow
we've got to bust the barriers and we
can't fear that we just can't um
and angela how about yourself well i'm
on my end um
yeah i i have i have contemplating i
know we have a bar i've heard anyway in
burbank called tenhorn flats they're
preparing to open on thursday now i
can't
it costs so much for an attorney and
stuff to get
that license back and i i did not
that video was completely by accident i
didn't ask
for any of this and for me i am calling
them
out because i want them gone
i want them held responsible and i want
it changed so the restaurant association
here
you know i think one thing everybody has
told me
is my video has inspired them to start
really speaking up and start fighting
and staying
in the game and i'm i don't i'm not at a
point where i want to risk my liquor
license or
my health permit yet because we did get
a big win
with the courts so now the next step is
you know it's like david and goliath
i hit the you know we hit the the giant
in the head and he's busy and now
now it's newsom now we're coming after
you know the rest of it so he falls
because
you know small business owners here i
mean it costs so much for my business my
business
cost me half a million dollars but i
worked 10 years in this business
to pay off so i had a retirement you
know and that's paid off in june
of this coming year and i don't have the
the funds to legally fight them so
i mean if i if i defy them and they take
the license
you know i may never hold a license
again because i don't have the money to
to fight them so i'm choosing this route
and the restaurant
association is plowing in they've called
me i'm going to be meeting with them and
politicians and
you know i'm just trying to be as vocal
and beyond
just talk to everybody as much as i can
and and
and not be political because it's not
about politics it's about people
and what i'm amazed and astonished about
is you know this is a very liberal state
and and i was afraid that i would have a
backlash and they would think oh
you know i don't believe in mass or i
want people to die or
for the most part i've had so many you
know calling me going
we've had it you're right we want them
out like
it's now starting to be the people you
know
saying get we want new leaders we want
you know so that has been
very inspiring to me very inspiring and
i try
very hard not to be political because
once you do
you get caught in this baseball match
and trampled all of us people in
in the middle you know what i mean like
we're just trying to live our life
and provide a you know jobs and a good
home
i have a son in indiana i have a
grandchild on the way
you know i'm just trying to live the
american dream i i'm not
you know
both of you for risking starting a
business
and trying to create jobs and staying in
business and obviously you got pushed
back to a point where 118 days for you
david
of being shut down there's only so much
you can do until you
put a man in a corner to rise up and say
listen i just got to stop and there's
only so much can be done for angela for
you to go out there and spend that 60 80
thousand dollars
all you know is next thing you know a
week later they shut you down and across
the street 50 feet away from you
they set up the same exact thing because
the entertainment industry is now
considered
so i applaud both of you uh angela we're
gonna put your
gofundme below for anybody who wants to
support you david i believe you have one
as well we're going to put that below as
well for folks who can go out there and
contribute and how can people find you
if there's
others in the restaurant community who
want to get a hold of you what's the
best way to get a hold of both of you
they can reach me and and i'm glad you
said that because
um you know i have been speaking with a
lot of people and
um i'm trying to get other businesses on
so that they can speak and i have a a
bunch already and i will take in anybody
else and i will pass their names along
so they can go to ph
saloon on facebook and leave me a
message or they can go to instagram it's
pineapple hill
saloon and leave a direct message i have
my bartenders are answering them
they give me their info i i would love
it because i am planning
something else as well i'm doing some
protests and other things
but one one last thing i want to say is
i i you know i'm not i'm like you
i'm not very good with words and i say
things wrong and
you know i i don't have a college degree
you know
no more nobody you know and and and
i go to to people that inspire me and i
have this quote in front of me every
time i talk
and it's from bob marley of all people i
do
you never know how strong you are until
being strong is the only choice you have
and you reminded me of that quote when
you were speaking
well thank you that's uh that means a
lot to me i'll remember that and i'll
write that down myself yeah
david how about if people want to get a
hold of you david what's the best way to
get it
um i'm on i'm dave moore's it's a d
r at d d r daily grind
on twitter we're gonna put your link
below as well for people to be able to
message you
uh anybody that's in a restaurant or
business uh world that you wanna reach
out to them
you can go to instagram with angela or
her website or you can go on twitter and
send dave
a message as well with that being said
angela david thank you so much for being
a guest on valuetainment we're also on
facebook
thanks for what you're doing can i say
one more thing
five seconds i remember you asked her
about at some point if she'd be willing
to move out of that state and i got to
tell you
if they drive me out of the state they
closed me down uh i will move on to this
state i'm not where would you go to if
you left the state what state would you
live in you want
sunshine i'm looking for more sunshine
my wife knows that i don't like it
and we have i've threatened for years in
fact it's a joke and much my family been
on my life and i tell her
you can't bury me here you can't spread
my ashes here there's nothing i like
about michigan but i'm here because my
family's here and i was raised and born
so here i am
but i'm looking to go west a little bit
i don't think it'll be out there in that
expensive territory
no don't go to florida
maybe southern indiana so i can stay
close to my kids and stuff oh yes
nice there's indiana by the way the
roads are nice everything's going pretty
good down there and
yeah the economy is great the red state
down there is doing well and they're
treating people fairly so yeah they are
if they drive me out i got no problem
selling everything and moving down there
i guess
yeah i'll do something else we'll figure
it out awesome
thank you thank you so much for being a
guest thank you so much
these were not actors these are two
business owners one in california one in
michigan both being affected by the
regulations and you know policies that
the governors and the mayors are coming
out with and you're seeing what's
happening to them having to shut down
what are your thoughts about what they
have to say you saw both of their
reactions watching each other's video
i'm curious to know
what you have to say about it and
outside of that if you watch this video
and you're seeing how states are being
affected by
no story is going to show us more about
what's going on with policies of state
than disney disneyland
in california shuts down and lays off 28
000 people
disney world in florida keeps going
keeps everybody employed all because of
policies if you're not seeing that video
click over here to watch that video and
if you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye
you